my mom is your character in this motion
know what she said she said it sounds
like a terrible idea
I'll need a year to plan it Oh for you I
know this is an opposite character to
who you are again yeah I don't mean
anybody I know someone no but I know a
lot of moms like yeah and it isn't
really about being a mom is about me a
person who is that person it's not
really just a mother I mean one of the
things I gotta learn is that mothers are
people and that's who they bring to
mother that realization Spanish yeah
that you're a person yeah I do
everyone has that Momo's our mom you can
snatch anybody in Hollywood and ambush
them and take them on vacation who would
it be frankly if I'm gonna snatch
somebody it would be Kate oh yeah
usually we talk about it all the time on
you gotta go away let's go do an
adventure together I like to walk baby
we've been talking about it for ten
years now we need to do it you know okay
would you take I think Frances McDormand
whoa fun she seems like a you'd like
really like yeah like I want to just you
know I want to see things during the day
but at night it seems fun to just kind
of sit and drink and talk does it change
the vibe when you're shooting in Hawaii
yes you have to remind yourself you're
working there area by working in hiya
Hawaii yeah you finished your work day
they have these drinks that are called
lava flows oh yeah and a half pina
colada with half strawberry daiquiri I
know love em oh I love it
oh my god I got it's no good you just
ordered it in you they know they're ugly
they were like we have a thing called a
lotta problem we could ask you guys your
boo might anyone speak like that and why
did they not a wire that our dresser was
it with humor tape bro let's loosen it
up a little bit how they can mess with
the wrong [ __ ] yeah go I'm gonna
count down I'm gonna do it 199
[Music]
Oh